what's up everybody welcome back to my
youtube channel richard on data if this
is your first time here my name is
Richard and this is the channel where we
talk about all things data data science
statistics and programming subscribe for
all kinds of data science related
content and hit the notification bell so
YouTube notifies you whenever I upload a
video all right so as you can probably
tell from the title of this video I just
hit 1,000 subscribers on this channel
last week and I would like to thank each
and every single one of you I started
this channel a few months ago primarily
to share my own opinions and experiences
from the data science field as a whole
because it's been my personal experience
there's way too much stuff that I see
out there especially from academia that
really over hypes and overemphasizes
things like neural networks and deep
learning now that's not to say at all
that those things aren't awesome I love
all that stuff but I think it leads a
lot of people to some seriously
unrealistic expectations about what the
field actually entails and what data
science really is so it's been my
mission to share my own perspective just
as somebody who's been in data science
for close to 6 years now I've also tried
to bring forward simple straightforward
and practical educational content
because in my opinion that's another
problem that's out there in the data
science field there's way too much
educational content out there and I
think a lot of it is very seriously
disconnected from the things people
actually do in their day to day if
they're working in a data science job a
lot of the stuff that's out there it's
way to surface level like reading a CSV
and pandas or it's just way too
theoretical so thank you to all of you
who've subscribed to my channel because
you've helped me make what it is so far
and I do actually read each and every
single comment that I get so keep
leaving me comments with your thoughts
as well as your take on what kinds of
topics I should cover next occasionally
I talk about things like communication
and data visualization and these are
super important things in the field but
unfortunately they can get
overlooked a little bit in favor of once
again cooler and sexier things but at
the end of the day you need to tell a
story with your data and to do that you
need to communicate well and some good
tools to do that are graphs and charts
so as a 1,000 subscriber special I
thought I would do something completely
different from what I usually do with
this channel usually what I'm doing what
this channel is I'm presenting my own
experiences or I'm teaching some kind of
content that way I can be a peer who's
been in data science for some time now
who for people who are aspiring to get
in the field they're currently in the
field now or maybe you're just an
interested observer I could be somebody
you can learn something from then if I'm
really lucky maybe I'm somebody whom you
can even share some laughs with along
the way well this video is different I
thought rather than doing something
serious where I'm talking about the data
science industry and whether it's gonna
die in a few years or I'm presenting
some kind of educational content on
statistics that I could do something
that's purely for entertainment purposes
there's this article about the 27 worst
graphs ever it was published in Business
Insider in the year 2013 but these
graphs stick around to haunt all of us
to this day so I thought it would be fun
to torture myself on camera and go
through all these graphs and give my own
thoughts and reactions to them now one
thing to note I'm only gonna go through
25 of the 27 because the other two sort
of delve into some subject matter
content that I really don't want to get
into in this channel if you're
interested in them the link will be in
the description so without further ado
enjoy my 1000 subscribers special
so here's graph number one and right off
the bat it's a pie chart which can
already tell you that it's not great but
to add insult to injury there's these
little sub components inside the pie
chunks so it's almost like a pie chart
inside of a pie chart or as I would
prefer to put it it's like suck inside
of suck now this one was discovered
inside some blog that was titled junk
charts so at least that was a pretty
accurate descriptor next up we have a
graph that represents the annual sales
of various fast-food chains in the US so
I guess the takeaway from this is yay
McDonald's I guess I'm just trying to
figure out why the GDP of Afghanistan is
on this chart either way the idea
they're trying to get at here is that
McDonald's has three times the annual
sales as Burger King but the actual area
here is nine times bigger so if you're
reading this graph you look at it and it
just confuses you at first and the moral
of the story is please don't use flashy
graphics like this when you're making a
graph or a chart now this next one I
guess is on major league soccer player
salaries and I'm not gonna lie this one
is so obnoxious looking and has so much
going on that I don't even aesthetically
even want to look at it I don't know
this might just be the American and me
coming out but this graph honestly makes
me care about soccer even less than I
already did before so I guess there's
one thing this graph accomplished moving
on to this next one this is from
Bloomberg now I guess all the
percentages next to the food at the top
are the imports and then if you look at
the bottom by the countries those are
the exports but there's way too much of
just moving my eyeballs around all over
the place that I have to do in order to
figure that out I'm really not sure
which thing annoys me more here the fact
that there's all these percentages at
the bottom and they're all four
different groups so you're looking at
them expecting them to add up to a
hundred and they don't or the fact that
there's an onion in the middle here and
there's this pie slice that's coming out
of it
like I really want to meet the person
who actually chops their onions like
that then this one is from Gallup and
it's a 2012 poll of the percentage of
LGBT individuals across each state now
number one here I guess was Hawaii at
five point one percent the last one here
was North Dakota that came in at one
point seven percent but you would never
know that from looking at
Graff because there's no information
whatsoever that you're gonna glean from
this color scale this next one is from
Globe and Mail and it's another
convoluted and overly complicated
infographic this one is on the gun laws
in each state I really don't know what
I'm supposed to be looking at here
there's way too much information on here
I mean I guess a lot of states in the
u.s. ban guns in the workplace so that's
one thing I learned I guess but I must
say the thing that annoys me the most
about this graph is the fact that it
looks like it's an alphabetical order
for parts of it and then it'll just stop
like at the top you've got New York New
Mexico New Hampshire Nevada
what the hell California whatever now on
the threat of firearms we have an even
worse graph this is almost an exercise
in how many different colors that you
can splash onto a page while still
getting as little information across as
possible I really have no idea what all
these purple and orange and gray pie
chunks next to Hawaii are I mean maybe
there's some context here that I'm
missing to get this but if I need that
outside context that much to understand
your graph it's because your graph is
bad now we've got a graph on the
drinking age and the various provinces
of Canada wonderful stuff first of all
nobody and let me reiterate that nobody
expresses age as seventeen point six
years eighteen point two years if you're
actually one of those people send me a
DM and I will bring you on this channel
to interview you and I mean that but
really did we seriously need a graph
that has only two unique numbers on it I
don't know what to tell you now this
next one was described by Edward Tufte
day as the worst graph ever made and
honestly I'm looking at this chart and
it kind of looks like I took a sheet of
white paper and then just puked all over
it and I think that if I did that that
would honestly be more informative and
give you more information than this
chart does this next one is from Fox
News
and there's a lot of problems here so
first of all the time points on the
graph are all equally distant from each
other but they're not represented as
equally distant on this graph and then
for no reason whatsoever there is a line
that's drawn through these points even
though this information is not linear
I guess they took the y-axis difference
and then just through that difference on
to the y-axis
I don't know I'm probably reading too
much into it this graph sucks
so everybody's talking about fake news
and fake polls these days can we all
start talking about fake graphs and fake
charts that'd be great and apparently in
the world of this graph eight point six
percent is higher than nine percent I'm
offended you guys I'm offended as a
taxpayer I'm offended as a data
scientist I'm offended as a human and
now we have another one from Fox News
now I have to say at first glance this
one isn't quite as badly designed as the
others but it's still pretty seriously
misleading first of all the y-axis
doesn't start at zero I guess it starts
at a hundred and fifty thousand now
that's not always a deal-breaker with a
graph but you could tell that they did
that by design because they're purposely
trying to exaggerate the difference
between 2012 and 2013 but worse than
that is the fact that the x-axis here
isn't even accurate because what they
did here was they found these random
months from each of these years they're
actually graphing those months and then
they just slapped the year label on them
so it's just confusing so somebody at
Fox News needs to find their data
professionals and somebody needs to get
fired all over all these because these
are ridiculous
hey as Business Insider points out the
other side of the aisle sucks too this
is taken from Barack Obama's 2013 State
of the Union address I'm really confused
about why this is presented as a Venn
diagram considering China's and the
United States's investments in renewable
energy are completely separate and
distinct piles of money but even on top
of that China has
what Drupal the number of people that
the US does and has different energy
needs but whatever thanks Obama
I thought things were gonna change
apparently not this next one is from the
Winnipeg Sun in Canada and I must admit
this one might be the most
unintentionally accurate of all of them
I mean I can sort of relate to this one
so the Patriots they win for the 10th
straight time in a row the halftime show
is boring so if somebody actually came
up to me and they asked what my favorite
part of the Super Bowl was I would
probably look them in the eye and just
say no so this graph has that going for
it I guess
and here we have more politicians doing
bad Venn diagrams this one courtesy of
MIT Romney's 2012 presidential campaign
and this one is equally ridiculous I
mean I guess what he's trying to do here
is he's trying to use the black part
that's overlapping to represent the gap
between the blue and the red parts but
that's quite literally the exact
opposite of what the overlapping part of
a Venn diagram is supposed to represent
you know what Mark Twain said back in
the day that there are three kinds of
lies lies damned lies and statistics
why didn't he throw politicians into
that mix I feel like that was a really
gross oversight on his part all right
enough politics
here's one from scientific literature
now if this one tells the incredibly
compelling and exciting story that
susceptibility allele frequency starts
at zero then goes to zero
it's zero for some more time and then it
ends at zero congratulations you took up
half a page to say exactly nothing do
you want a cookie for that this next one
again I think is from scientific
literature and now in all walks of life
generally I try to stay away from using
to absolute of statements because things
are complex they're nuanced and there's
exceptions to everything but in this
case I feel completely confident in
saying that in the entire history of
graphical phenomena right now and in the
entire future until mankind dies off
there has never been there is not now
and there will never
any set of circumstances in which you
should ever use a 3-d cylinder plot
awkward looking clumsy hard to read
confusing I've said all that I need to
say here's some more bad 3d graphs for
you now I can't even look at this one
without getting a headache and I mean
when I was preparing this video I was
squinting at this one and trying to look
and distinguish the difference between
South Korea and Vietnam but then I
started feeling like I was getting a
seizure so I gave up and I decided I
would try to do something that hurts my
eyeballs less like stare at the Sun for
a couple hours or something this next
one is from LinkedIn so I guess this
Kirsten person and I have no skills in
common no views in common no connections
in common so right off the bat my first
thought was well that's been great to be
Kirsten I guess but I'm also kind of
taking this with multiple tablespoons of
salt but that's me this one is from The
Wall Street Journal and it's all about
Obama's divided nation I don't know what
do you guys think does this look really
divided to you looks extremely divided
to me I don't know what else you want me
to say and now we've got one which has
received the title of worst pie chart of
all time now I have to say that is some
seriously below the belt stuff like
that's pretty much like being told
you're the shortest kid in kindergarten
I swear I've looked at this exact graph
way too many times because clearly I
have nothing better to do with my time
and I'm still trying to figure out
exactly what this big blue section in
the middle is we may never know we may
all be better off for that this next one
is from Gizmodo and they were trying to
communicate that the new iPad has a
battery life that 70% longer than the
old iPad but people can't help
themselves and they have to change the
entire area so that it's way bigger than
70% a difference between the new and the
old you know I may have let these guys
off the hook if they had incorporated
into this graph that the new iPad forces
you to buy some new charger and that new
charger is 70% more expensive than the
old one but but no they they couldn't do
that and if you thought that one was bad
we have probably the worst one on this
entire list
apparently 29.4 is double of 0.7 2.4 is
double of zero 30.9 is actually greater
than 50 6.9 everybody is addicted to
opiates and booze and cocaine
the universe is broken and everything is
stupid and next up you guys know what I
dislike even more than a pie chart when
you have 32 pie charts and I dislike
them even more when there's some weird
stacking effect going on for most of
them like remember earlier in this video
when I said that there has never been
nor is there now nor will there ever be
in the future any circumstance in which
you should use a 3-d cylinder chart
yeah I'm pretty comfortable saying the
exact same thing about stacked pie
charts too then here we are on the last
one of this list which is good because I
really don't know how much more of this
I can take this is all about work place
commute and at this point I really don't
know what else to say I mean I guess New
York City uses a lot of public transit
and Houston doesn't so I'd be really
interested to see a follow up of this
kind of thing after the pandemic is all
said and done but in virtually any style
that's not this one like do some kind of
style that's better than this like pie
charts yes you actually got me to
recommend using pie charts as an
alternative to what you were doing
before I hope you're proud of yourself
all right if you're still watching this
you probably feel like your brain needs
a bath by this point and if there's
anything serious that you can take away
from this whatsoever
it's that you should strive to make
simple clear easy-to-understand graphs
otherwise who knows your graph just
might end up getting taken by Business
Insider they post an article about it
and then some other guy on the internet
makes bad jokes and makes fun of your
graph
and nobody wants that so thanks for
watching this video if you enjoyed it
and you'd like to support my work the
most helpful thing that you could do for
me would be to share this video
otherwise at least consider smashing the
like button and also leave me a comment
down below and let me know which one you
thought was the worst graph thank you to
everybody who subscribed to my channel
so far and hopefully many more to come
as we move forward so until next time
Richard on data